In DreamWorks animated movie, The Boss Baby,
30 Rock star Alec Baldwin lends his voice
to a business-suit-wearing, briefcase-carrying
baby, whose arrival at his family's home causes
all sorts of chaos.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in my last video I revealed some fun facts
you probably didn't know about The Boss Baby,
but now, in this video, I want to let you
in on some cool easter eggs, hidden details,
and movie references in the film.
Before I get started, I'm giving away a second
copy of this amazing hardback book from Titan
called "The Art of The Boss Baby" which contains
loads of concept art, storyboards, and info
about the movie.
All you need to do for a chance to win is
subscribe and leave a comment on this video
about The Boss Baby movie or your favourite
easter egg from the film.
And for bonus ways to enter, check out the
Gleam link in the video description below.
Ok, quick warning: there are spoilers ahead,
so if you've not seen the movie yet, why not
come back here after you've seen the film!
When Tim and Boss Baby's parents have to go
on a work-trip to Las Vegas, they leave their
children at home with their new babysitter,
Eugenia, who's actually really Francis E.
Francis's brother Eugene dressed up in women's
clothes.
This part of the film heavily references Disney's
1964 classic movie Mary Poppins.
Just look at Eugenia's clothing, including
her little hat and flower, the way Francis
E Francis calls her 'practically perfect in
every way', the way Boss Baby refers to her
as 'Scary Poppins', and also the way she flies
through the air using her umbrella.
As Eugenia aka Eugene chases them down the
street, Boss Baby tells Tim he must cycle
faster if they're going to escape, at which
point the movie takes us inside Tim's mind
where he imagines himself and Boss Baby sailing
on a stormy sea as they're pursued by an enormous
whale with the face of Eugenia!
This scene tips its hat to the 1956 film Moby
Dick and the classic novel on which it was
based.
Also, during that chase scene through the
streets, Tim imagines himself and Boss Baby
on a motorcycle jumping through a ring of
fire over a moving train, which is a little
tribute to the many airborne stunts of the
legendary daredevil performer, Evel Knievel.
If you were thinking that Tim's talking alarm
clock, Wizzie the wizard, sounds rather familiar,
that's because actor James McGrath who voices
him is particularly skilled at celebrity impressions,
and based Wizzie's voice on actor Ian McKellen,
who famously played Gandalf in Peter Jackson's
Lord of the Rings and Hobbit movies.
And, the line that Wizzie says every morning,
'Wake up, little halflings!', is also a nod
to the novels of JRR Tolkien in which 'halflings'
is another name for 'hobbits'.
Director Steven Spielberg's iconic action-adventure
movies, including the Indiana Jones films,
were an inspiration for the Boss Baby filmmakers,
particularly when it came to creating and
editing the fantasy sequences dreamt up by
Tim.
So, when Tim is running through a jungle,
flying a spaceship, or fighting a gorilla,
the movie's editor channelled the editing
style used in Spielberg's classic movies.
But whip-cracking archaeologist Indiana Jones
wasn't the only character that inspired Tim's
wild flights of imagination.
The filmmakers also took cues from the Looney
Tunes cartoon character Ralph Phillips, who,
like Tim, was a young boy with a vivid imagination
and a tendency to daydream.
Likewise, the movie's graphic, stylised look
is also an homage to Warner Brothers' Looney
Tunes cartoons, and several Disney films from
the golden age of animation influenced the
movie too.
For example, the fantasy scene where Tim saves
his parents from inside a shark by using hot-sauce
is a riff on Disney's 1940 animated film Pinocchio,
where Pinocchio starts a fire to escape from
the huge whale Monstro that swallowed him
and his father Geppetto.
Another of director Steven Spielberg's movies
also left its mark on the neighbourhood where
Tim's family lives.
According to The Boss Baby director Tom McGrath,
they set the movie in small-town suburbia
in a past that combines the 1970s and 80s,
and for the appealing look of Tim's neighbourhood,
they took cues from the much-loved early 80s
movie, ET.
You probably noticed that the magnetic letters
on the fridge change from Tim's name to 'Baby'
and that Tim's photo gets covered over with
baby pictures once Boss Baby arrives.
But what you might not have spotted is that
before Boss Baby arrives, Tim is wearing a
T-shirt with the number '1' on it.
However, just after Tim spots Boss Baby arriving
in a taxi, Tim doesn't change his clothes
but the number on his T-shirt does change
from '1' to '2' as he rushes down the stairs
to find out what's going on, which of course
signals that he no longer feels like number
one priority in the family.
During a big action scene where Tim chases
Boss Baby and his toddler team around the
garden as Boss Baby drives a toy cop car,
there's a musical hat tip to the theme tune
of the 1970s TV series S.W.A.T., which followed
the escapades of a Special Weapons and Tactics
team.
And the movie's action scenes also make use
of sound effects from the popular 1970s sci-fi
action series, The Six Million Dollar Man,
which starred actor Lee Majors as a special
agent with bionic implants that gave him superhuman
abilities.
And, of course, because the character of Boss
Baby is brought to life by actor Alec Baldwin,
the movie includes homages to roles he's played
on the big and small screen.
For instance, during one of Boss Baby's meetings
with his Special Mission Team of Staci, The
Triplets, and Jimbo, there's a lovely nod
to another demanding businessman Baldwin played
in the 1992 movie Glengarry Glen Ross.
In that film, his character uttered the now-famous
lines "Put that coffee down.
Coffee's for closers".
And in this movie that becomes: "Put that
cookie down.
Cookies are for closers", which Boss Baby
says to Jimbo when he's telling him off for
eating cookies before they've succeeded in
their mission.
The character of Boss Baby also clearly plays
on Alec Baldwin's award-winning turn as executive
Jack Donaghy in the critically acclaimed TV
comedy 30 Rock, to the point that the movie's
business-savvy baby is pretty much a mini-Jack-Donaghy
in diapers, barking orders, spouting management
advice, and talking about corporate retreats.
And just like 30 Rock's Donaghy who idolises
his boss Don Geiss, wanting to follow in his
footsteps and be promoted to the top job when
Geiss retires, so too Boss Baby admires his
manager, and is striving for a promotion and
a corner office of his own.
Now, what are your favourite easter eggs,
hidden details and references in the movie?
And did you spot any others I missed?
Let me know in the comments below!
Don't forget to subscribe and comment for
your chance to win a second copy of this fantastic
The Art of The Boss Baby hardback book!
If you liked this video, do also check out
my Boss Baby Secrets video about the making
of the movie and also my animation playlist
here.
And as always I appreciate your likes, shares,
and comments on my videos.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!